right now a group of film editors is
waiting for the next envelope to be
opened now what precisely is a film
editor at the moment he's an extremely
nervous gentleman or lady because
editors come in your choice of two sexes
to explain more fully their function
the editors not the sexes an exciting
new star who is herself a nominee this
evening and her recently acquired
personal leading man will please enter
naam and take over miss Jo Ann Woodward
mr. Paul Newman
a motion picture is photographed in bits
and pieces when all the film has been
exposed and processed somebody has to
fit the pieces together in continuity
that is the basic function of the film
editor will you read the nominees mr.
human with pleasure mrs. Newman those
nominated for the best achievement in
film editing our Peter Taylor for the
Bridge on the River Kwai whirring low
for gunfight at OK Corral Viola Lawrence
and Jerome Tom's for PAL Joey
Arthur P Schmidt and Phillip W Anderson
for sayonara and Daniel Mandel for a
witness for the prosecution of the
winner mr. Newman you read it I'm too
nervous the Bridge on the River Kwai
Peter Taylor
William Lyon will accept the award for
mr. Taylor in accepting this award for
Peter Taylor who is in London and cannot
be here I joined with him and thanking
the members of the Academy and to mr.
Sam Spiegel a producer of the picture
the bridge on the river kwai thank you